[Music]
so from an evolutionary perspective 1020
thousand years ago distractions actually
kept us alive when you're sleeping in
your cave or in a village it could be a
tiger coming to eat you or a villager
trying to attack you and 10 or 20,000
years ago those things with paying
attention to the people that could
understand those patterns were the
people that lived in today's society
fast forwarding now we live in so many
distractions we have so many things
coming on us but none of them are life
or death so everything is accentuated
because of that and what of a lot of our
music does it actually starts
fundamentally and how to balance your
brain or how to almost take advantage of
those evolutionary principles and we use
that as a starting point and we layer
our music on top of that from there
what's really important about our
company is that we are science first so
what that means is we take it seriously
and every single thing that we do we try
to validate with science one of the
really exciting things about our focus
product specifically is we have a grant
from the National Science Foundation to
help us evaluate is this can be a
preliminary step a combination or a
complete replacement for a TD and ADHD
medications it's with the same kind of
scientific rigor that we also apply for
our relax or meditation and our sleep
product basically the the ATD in the
ADHD studies contain how do we replicate
the same kinds of intense focus that
these drugs do but on demand and in a
more controlled environment so when you
take you know these different kinds of
medications they last for a certain
period of time and that's not always
needed sometimes you just need 30
minutes or an hour maybe two hours of
intense focus and then when you're done
you can stop and really what we're doing
is we're using fMRI EEG data to help us
validate that this is something
that can peak that state on demand with
no use of drugs and just the neural
phase locking in our music and the
reason I'm passionate about it is
because there are so many people in the
world and let alone just America that
are having challenges with a DD ADHD
right now we prescribe so much
medication to kids that's very close to
cocaine and what's happening is we're in
the cycle of prescribing now I'm not
trying to erase those drugs and I'm
trying to what we're trying to do is
actually give someone another option
because right now you have ADHD you have
these problems you're a parent you just
want your kid to study to focus to do
well and what often other options do you
have it's a really big deal because if
we can help people have another option
we could be a preliminary step we could
be a combination or it could be a
replacement altogether and have someone
be able to control this advanced focus
on demand is extremely important because
of that reason I think as we move
forward as a culture it's really about
just having choices at the end of the
day and what brain FM is is a brand-new
choice that people have to be able to
have that effect that they're looking
for so brain FM we create functional
music to help you focus relax and sleep
better it's all backed by science
research and evidence in the continual
improvement of that so what that
basically means is how do we produce
music that is designed from mental
states from the ground up and what we do
is we actually start with a mental state
in mind and we have a brain protocol and
we craft music around that so in the end
of the day you're just listening to
normal music that has carrot
characteristics specifically designed to
help you get your mental state on demand
so when you listen to our music you'll
hear all different kinds of genres of
music we have electronic we have Mozart
we have piano we even have lo-fi and
what the secret is is actually the
neural phase-locking which is a pattern
process we've developed to create these
characteristics that encourage your
to arrive at that mental state as fast
as possible you can think of neural
phase locking is actually a combination
of a lot of different principles that
create these characteristics in your
brain and what happens is when you're
listening to music or really just right
now your brain is firing almost like a
Christmas tree so when you plug one in
it's all blinking at random different
times and what our music does it aligns
all of those blinking lights to blink at
the same time to get there into that
state and then as long as you're
listening to the music stay in that
state for the rest of your period
[Music]
so I think building brain fm
we have to be careful because what we're
doing is we're introducing a new tool
that has the capability to help a lot of
people but can also be viewed in a way
that isn't really the intention where
we're trying to help people no matter
what language you speak and how many how
much money you make to be a better
person on demand and there's a lot of
regulations doing that some are from
critics saying like hey this is
something that can't be done because
it's been tried before some of it is
maybe from the government some of it is
from all these different things you know
we have a consumer side but we also have
a medical side and I think it's really
important that we view this in a way
that is actually an indicator or a
barrier that we have to rise up in meet
and exceed so it's not just about oh man
this is this is annoying this is
something that is that people are
cautious of I welcome that I I want to
take someone's curiosity or skepticism
and match that and explode it and how do
we use this as a way to conduct our
company in our future company in a way
that aligns with those principles so
that we're always testing our own
product first before we're told we're
always offering information and data
before someone is telling us to do so
and we are the ones leading the charge
or the release of this information and
really building upon it because we know
that that's going to make us better
[Music]